[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So welcome back, everyone.
So for this next
portion of our program,
we're bringing together a
panel, an all-star panel focused
on global perspectives
on citizenship.
I think, particularly,
given the comments
we've just heard
from Judy and Tom,
that we recognize that
concepts around citizenship
and community participation
really vary significantly,
dependent on your context.
And that can, of course,
bring in multiple factors--
things like locale, what
world region you're from,
your gender, your age, your
socioeconomic status, and so
on.
So we take this broad
array of perspectives,
and then we add one more
that's critically important.
And that's the focus of
our discussion today--
and one that cross-cuts
all of those.
And that is the
experience of being
a person with a disability.
And from the initial cadre of
disability and civil rights
advocates up through
today's ADA Generation,
it's clear that concepts
around citizenship today,
and what that means,
and how you strive
for reaching those rights,
and advocate for your needs,
it looks different now than
it did 30 or 40 years ago.
And then you layer
in contextual factors
related to global citizenship,
and that brings another layer.
So this panel is
really to focus on all
of those
multidimensional aspects
of what it means to be a
citizen and to fully participate
in your community as a person
with a disability here,
now, in 2018, and
how we got here.
So I'm going to keep my
intros brief because you want
to hear from these panelists.
And the bios are
in your program,
as was mentioned earlier.
So please take a moment
to look at those.
But briefly, we're
going to be starting
on this side of the
table and moving down.
We'll first hear
from Maria Town.
Welcome, Maria.
Maria is the director of the
Mayor's Office for People
With Disabilities for
the City of Houston,
where she advocates for the
rights and needs of citizens
with disabilities related
to everything from hurricane
relief, to immigration,
to incarceration--
a number of topics,
particularly at the local level.
But I think everyone who knows
Maria knows that she's a rising
star in the field and already
has a great depth of leadership
on these topics.
And she was a former
senior associate director
in the Obama White House
Office of Public Engagement,
so also with some federal
experience, as well.
Next to Maria is
Ari Ne'eman, who's
a well-known leader in
the self-advocacy movement
and currently serves as CEO
of MySupport.com, something
that's definitely worth checking
out when you have a moment.
Ari is involved in
numerous consulting roles
across many sectors related
to disability policy
and is really seen as an
expert in this regard,
particularly working with groups
such as the American Civil
Liberties Union.
His voice is really out there.
I actually just read
your blog post, Ari,
from the Health Affairs
Blog a couple of days ago.
So really cross-cutting
issues of disability policy
across multiple sectors and with
a real wealth of experience.
Charlotte McClain-Nhlapo,
far to my left,
is a long-term friend and
a global disability advisor
to the World Bank
Group, where she
focuses on disability,
inclusive development,
and also was previously
appointed by President Obama
to lead USAID's work on
disability, including how you
think about developing
policies in various regions
around the world and
country strategies
at the local level for
program implementation.
Charlotte just arrived
here to Boston from Rome,
as is usually the case.
I feel like Charlotte's always
coming in from somewhere
fabulous around the world.
And so we really appreciate
her being here despite lag
and taking the
effort to join us.
So really thrilled to
get this session started.
What we're going to do is hear
from each of our panelists
individually for
about 15 minutes,
just to hear their
overall thoughts
and how they think about
citizenship from their lens.
After that, we'll have
a moderated discussion
amongst ourselves, and then
we'll open it up for Q&A.
So without further ado, I'll
pass along to you, Maria.
- Thank you, Cheri.
[APPLAUSE]
So I thought to kick
my comments off,
I would reference
a Harvard alumn.
In his farewell address,
President Barack Obama
said, "It falls to
each of us to be
those anxious, jealous
guardians of our democracy.
Embrace the joyous task we have
been given to continually try
to improve this
great nation of ours
because for all of our
outward differences,
we, in fact, share
the same proud type--
the most important office
in a democracy, citizen.
Citizen.
So you see, that's what
our democracy demands.
It needs you, not just
when there's an election,
not just when you can serve
your own narrow interests,
but over the full
span of a lifetime.
If you're tired of arguing
with strangers on the internet,
try talking to one of
them in real life."
And when he left
office, he said,
"And now I'm going to take
on my most important title,
more important than
president, more
important than prime
minister-- citizen."
And I think that that's
an interesting quote
to sort of start this
conversation because when
we talk about citizenship,
I think that there's
an assumption embedded
in that, which
is the assumption of
active citizenship.
When we talk about
people being citizens,
we're assuming that there's some
sort of activity and production
connected to what
they are doing,
because they are an
active participant
in our government's or many
governments' social contracts.
And that assumption of
activity and production
has been used to
discriminate against people
with disabilities from
the very beginning
because, as Judy mentioned,
we have been marked
as people who just
have needs, as people
who are solely consumers.
And when you contextualize it in
the American code of Protestant
work ethic moment, the idea that
people with disabilities cannot
contribute and cannot be
productive really endangers
our own ability to engage
in active citizenship.
And it's interesting.
If you look at photos
from many of the protests
in the initial disability
civil rights movement,
you see signs that say, we
want to be taxpayers, too.
And we laugh at that.
And we can think that
maybe the only people
in the world who
want to be taxpayers
are people with disabilities.
So I'm giving you a kind of
broad, historical perspective
because, really, when
we talk about disability
and citizenship
together, in many ways,
disability status and identity
has been seen as antithetical
to citizenship.
And so now I want to talk
about some more specific issues
that I'm dealing
with at a local level
that I think highlight this.
One, and they're all current--
I find it interesting
that every Harvard student
that I've met who has been
disabled has been an immigrant.
Now, mind you,
I've only met four.
That's a very limited sample.
[LAUGHTER]
But all of them, every single
one of them, have been--
had a disability.
And most of them share
the same story, which
is that, I had a disability.
And my family decided
to move to America
because they knew that I would
have more rights here, and be
able to access education,
and have a chance of getting
a job because of things
like the Rehabilitation Act
and the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
And so when I think
about immigration,
disability is a
huge part of that.
There are people who come
to the United States, people
with disabilities,
because they have a better
chance of succeeding here than
they do in their home country.
And in Houston, one
in four Houstonians
was not born in
the United States.
I would say that, in many ways,
we are a city of immigrants.
We have the largest
refugee population
in the United States.
And so currently, the
Trump administration
is considering a rule called
the Public Charge Rule,
which would prevent immigrants
who receive public supports,
like the Supplemental Nutrition
Assistance Program or housing
vouchers, from attaining
visas, green cards,
and full citizenship.
So what is that
actually an attack on?
That's an attack
on poor immigrants,
and that's an attack
on disabled immigrants.
And in the City of
Houston, we stand, one,
firmly against
this proposed rule
and recognize not only how it
will impact those individuals
who have been so brave to leave
their home and to come here,
but our whole-- our
citizenry as a whole.
And so I want to give you some
numbers and some examples.
What we found for other bills--
whether they're
at the state level
or at the federal
level-- for bills
that target
immigrants, what we see
is individuals not seeking
city services that they
are entitled to,
like vaccinations,
like TB vaccinations.
That puts all of us
at a health risk.
By the way, vaccinate
your children, please.
And we also-- there was a
bill at the Texas state level
called SB 4, which
targeted immigrants.
And what we found is
that there were 70% fewer
reports of domestic
violence in the Latinx
community in Houston.
Does that mean that
domestic violence
was happening at a lesser rate?
Absolutely not.
It means that people
were scared to report.
were getting hurt.
And so now, if you
think that people maybe
won't try to access
things like SNAP or WIC,
it means that children won't get
access to the food they need.
That's putting our
whole citizenry at risk.
And so hearkening to
what Judy was saying,
until we can get to the
point where we realize
that social justice movements
connected to citizenship
need to embrace disability--
not just for individuals, but
also so our whole democracy can
continue to sustain itself--
we're going to continue
having discussions like this.
There's also an
economic piece to this.
We note that immigrants in
Houston generate $14.75 million
in economic activity.
Preventing them from
accessing public programs that
support economic stability will
destabilize our whole economy.
Again, it will infringe
upon everyone's ability
to be an active citizen.
Another very recent and
wonderful piece of news
is that felons in
Florida now can vote.
[APPLAUSE]
Exactly.
So I think it was Referendum
Number 4 on their ballot--
restore voting rights
to people who--
felons who had
served their time.
Florida is not the
only state to do this.
We do this in Texas.
What that means is that one
million people can now vote.
That is 9.2% of Florida's
voting-age population.
Mhm.
And when we look at criminal
justice, at least 80%
of people in the
criminal justice system
are people with disabilities.
So the ballot
initiative in Florida--
it's a race issue.
It's a gender issue.
It's a disability issue.
It's an enfranchisement issue.
And it's a citizenship issue.
And all of those are connected.
So thinking about
things that we can
do around enhancing
people's ability
to be active citizens in
the context of disability,
we need more ballot
initiatives like Referendum 4.
I don't know-- how much
time do I have left?
OK, great.
Something that I've given
a lot of thought to,
and that I think everyone on
this panel could speak to,
is people with disabilities'
rights to privacy.
And privacy, I think,
today is on everyone's mind
in new ways because of hacks
at Facebook and Google--
working for the federal
government at the Office
of Personnel Management.
So I think everyone has a
greater sense of how tentative
their privacy really is.
People with
disabilities, I think,
often just abandon
their sense of privacy
because, so often, the programs
that we are forced to rely on
in order to survive
require us to describe,
in great detail,
aspects of our lives
that are often our
most private moments.
And so when we think
about things like a right
to privacy, for people
with disabilities,
that's not the most
resonant concept.
However, you would
think that for folks
who maybe don't get to access as
much privacy as everybody else,
we wouldn't need to tell
our stories because everyone
else would already know them.
The opposite is true.
Well, doctors need to know
measurements of our bodies
and the regularity of
our bowel movements.
When state agencies need to
know exactly how much money we
are making at every
point in the day,
when our communities establish
working groups to check up
on us because they want to
make sure we're kept safe--
you know, and it makes
it harder to have
an intimate night at home--
you would think that people
would get our stories.
But instead, when we
try to tell our stories,
to actually articulate ourselves
and maybe expose our truths,
people don't want to hear that.
And so what does being
a private citizen
look like as a person
with a disability?
Working in natural
disasters and emergencies,
as I've done in
Houston, there are
a lot of people who talk
about registries for people
with disabilities, in
order to make sure we
can get rescued and be safe.
And I think registries
are very ineffective.
I think that they are often
a waste of taxpayer dollars.
And I don't think that
people with disabilities
are inclined to use
them, because if you're
a person with a disability,
more likely than not,
you already exist
in many registries
all over the country.
If someone were able to use
data modeling and pulling
information from
Medicaid or from SNAP,
you could absolutely
pinpoint where
most people with disabilities
exist in the United States
right now.
So again, what does it mean
to be a private citizen
for a person with a disability?
Finally-- this is a
little bit different--
when we think, again,
about the historic,
people with disabilities
are only consumers.
They're not producers,
therefore citizenship is tough.
Within the disability
community, I
think we actually have a group
of super citizens, a group
of people who have been very
impactful to the disability
rights movement.
And those are veterans.
These are individuals
who have chosen--
although we can unpack that--
to potentially sacrifice
themselves for their country.
And when they become wounded,
whether in the line of service
or not, they become a
person with a disability.
And it is the government's
responsibility
to care for them
because they have
been such an active citizen.
And so the connection of
veterans with disabilities
to all these services, to the
disability rights movement,
is very different.
And I think that their
understanding of citizenship
and their role in it
is also very different.
And so for me, it's interesting
to consider these opposite ends
of the spectrum.
Let's say people
with disabilities,
like myself, who were
born with disabilities--
who many would assume would be
on benefits for my whole life,
and that is not
necessarily a bad thing.
And on the opposite end, a very
young, virile man who became
injured in the line
of duty, and therefore
is valorized for his
active citizenship.
So just think on that.
And I think if we
could figure out
how to get a better conversation
going between those two groups,
among many others, we can
make progress on this issue.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- All right, yes.
Thank you, Maria.
I think a number of
really thoughtful topics.
Everyone, let those roll
around a little bit,
and maybe we can bring
them into the Q&A.
And certainly, we'll bring some
of those into our discussion,
as well.
Ari, we'd love to hear from you.
Thank you.
- Thank you all very
much for having me here.
One of the things that struck
me about this morning's keynote
was a comment Judy
made about how people
say those who discriminate
against people
with disabilities
don't really mean it.
And there's something very
powerful in naming that,
not least because the biggest
challenge the disability rights
movement has is helping the
public understand that we are,
in fact, a political issue.
Disability is political.
And in some ways,
one of the things
that's often been leveraged
as the disability community's
greatest asset--
the perception that
nobody wants to stand
against the interests
of disabled people
in a public way--
is also, really, our
greatest weakness.
Because if you don't
acknowledge disability policy
as a political issue,
as an area that
is rife with
potential conflict--
and those of us who work in
the world of disability policy
know that conflict
can be very intense.
But if you don't
acknowledge that,
then we end up with
this impression
that, really,
there are no sides.
Everyone is acting with
the best of intentions.
And people who
work on disability
are engaged in some
humanitarian rather than
a political project.
Judy talked about
the risks of that
in the context of
overt discrimination.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that
in the context of some
of the conflicts that
emerge around disability
service provision.
Over the course of the last 50--
at this point, 60 years--
I've been talking about
this for about a decade.
So over the course of
the last 60 years or so,
we've seen a tremendous
amount of change
in the disability
service provision system.
From 1960 to the present,
over 200 state institutions
for people with developmental
disabilities were closed,
and their residents
supported to live
with greater dignity,
autonomy, and independence
in the community.
If you look at 1977,
data we have from 1977--
in 1977, the average person
with a developmental disability
living outside a
family home was living
in a facility with
23 of their nearest
and dearest perfect strangers
they happened to share
a disability diagnosis with.
Today, the average residential
setting size is two.
There has been a
tremendous shift in the way
that disability
services are delivered,
are approached, and funded.
And by and large,
that shift has been
towards greater integration,
greater autonomy, and greater
choice for people
with disabilities.
Now, as we start to move
into new kinds of shifts
in the disability
service system--
and some of you here are aware
of some of the controversies
that disability
services face today,
such as the transition away
from sheltered workshops towards
community-integrated
employment--
what some folks
call second-order
deinstitutionalization--
the shift away from smaller
congregate settings like larger
group homes to individualized,
in-home services like
supported community living
or shared-living Hosla models.
All of that is running
into controversy.
And it's very important
for us to understand
that all of the prior
transitions that took place
were also intensely
controversial.
Some of you know I'm in
the process of writing
a book on the history of the
American disability experience,
from the Civil War
to the present day.
And one of the things that
really jumps out at you
is, in every generation,
going back to Union veterans,
disabled Union veterans
after the Civil War,
we've had these same conflicts
over what is the best
way to support, care for--
however we conceptualize it--
assist people with disabilities.
More recently, in the 1980s--
1970s, '80s, and '90s,
disability rights advocates
fought, in pretty much
every state capital
across the country,
on the question
of deinstitutionalization.
And the tricky thing
about disability politics
is that it doesn't
always match up
to the simple red-blue
divides that we're
used to in our country.
Some of you may know that one
of the most intense opponents
of deinstitutionalization and
community living for people
with disabilities in
the 1970s and '80s
were public sector
employee unions who
represented workers
and institutions that
didn't want to lose their job.
In 1975, the American
Federation of State, County,
and Municipal Employees
issued a pamphlet entitled Out
of Their Beds and Into
the Streets, working
to try and scare family
members of people
with developmental disabilities
that, if institutions
were closed, that folks would be
left without access to support.
That's, by and large,
not what happened.
We did see that to some degree
in the mental health context
because the community service
system was not funded there.
But in the DD context,
we've generally
seen a very positive
deinstitutionalization
experience.
But at the time,
we saw controversy.
So today, as we look at
new kinds of controversy,
it's important to have
that historical context.
Those of you who work
in Medicaid policy
may be familiar with
something called the Home
and Community-Based
Settings Rule.
In 2014, the Obama
administration
issued a rule that was designed
to speak to the fact that,
often, what we call community
living doesn't actually
afford people the kinds of
rights and opportunities
that we usually
consider characteristic
of life outside an institution.
And that in the initial waves
of deinstitutionalization,
sometimes what we ended
up doing was taking people
from a large building
where someone else got
to decide every
aspect of their life
and what they did for
every minute of the day,
and put them in a small
building where someone else got
to decide every
aspect of their life
and what they did for
every minute of the day.
And well, we do have a
fair amount of research
that shows that folks
are more likely to have
choice and autonomy
in smaller settings
than in larger
congregate settings.
Community also has to be
about the kinds of rights
and opportunities people have.
And so this rule, the Home and
Community-Based Settings Rule,
which every state has
until 2022 to comply with--
it was initially
going to be 2019.
The current administration
extended it to some degree--
is a multi-dimensional
definition of community.
It doesn't just talk about size,
although size is one factor.
It also talks about the kinds
of rights that people have.
Do people have the right to have
visitors in their own homes?
Do people have the right to
decide when they go to bed?
Do people have the right
to decide when they eat?
to decide where they live?
These basic concepts of choice--
which most people, with
and without disabilities,
who aren't in residential
service provision
have the opportunity
to make all the time--
are really core to the
question of whether
or not a setting
should be considered
community or
institutional in nature.
Generally speaking,
if you're 40 years old
and you have a bedtime,
you're institutionalized,
even if we're calling
it something else.
And the response and the
conflict that emerges here
is really oriented
around this tension
between autonomy and safety.
And this really gets into one
of the core questions of what
it means to be considered--
I know our theme is citizenship.
I don't want to limit it to
citizens-- but to be considered
a person, in the context of
our political, and social,
and especially human
services culture,
which is, to what extent do we
allow people, what disability
rights advocates have long
called, the dignity of risk?
Because while there are certain
things that people do need
support to avoid, where
there are life and death--
immediate life and
death consequences--
in fact, most of us make
decisions about our lives
that are oriented around
more than just basic safety.
How many of you have
ever had something
to eat that you later regretted?
How many of you
have ever been in
a romantic or
sexual relationship
that you've later regretted?
How many of you have
ever gone somewhere
that you've later regretted?
You think to yourself, why
did I waste my day like this?
How many of you have ever
done something dangerous?
Do you think your
life would be better
if you didn't have
the opportunity
to make those choices?
And so these are really one
of the core things that's
at stake when we talk about the
future of disability policy.
Are we going to be comfortable
with a controversial, conflict,
full, politicized
disability policy
conversation that has space
for people to make choices
that involve risk?
Or are we going to
go back to this idea
that there are no sides and
there are no politics when
it comes to disability?
We know that's not true.
But it's important for us
to really send a message
to the public that
that's not true.
I want to close by talking
about how this plays out
in academia, because
I know many of you
here have a very
significant role
to play in fields that
are far beyond just
disability studies
or disability policy.
When we talk about political
science and economics,
scholars have come up with a
wide variety of really valuable
methodological tools to
help us understand conflict,
and conflict between
different values
and different stakeholders
in our society.
And one of the challenges
that we run into
is that those tools
aren't always applied
in the context of disability.
Some of you who work
in political science
are familiar with the problem
of one person, one vote, one
time, which is a concept that
comes up in countries that
are embarking on the
transition to democracy,
but while they may
have elections,
have not built
sufficiently strong norms
around political
institutions to be
assured that free and
fair elections will
happen more than once.
And there is the risk that
elections will take place.
And then the winners will
prevent further choices
from being made, if the
polity changes its mind.
And here we have a
pretty basic recognition
that, in the
context of politics,
people need to have the right
to choose more than once.
And similarly, when we talk
about disability service
provision, often,
choice is conceptualized
in this very, very narrow way.
You have the right to choose
between group home A, group
home B, and an institution.
You have the right to choose
where you're going to live.
But we don't necessarily talk
about the kinds of choices
you should have
the right to make
after you make that decision.
In a very real way, we
run into this problem
of one person, one
choice, one time a lot
when we discuss residential
and employment service
provision for people with
significant disabilities
because there's a great
deal of focus that
goes into that initial choice,
but not a great deal of focus
into the kinds of choices that
occur every day around when
to eat, when to wake up,
who to spend time with,
and the ability to revise
our earlier choices.
So I want to close by saying
that people with disabilities
are fighting, in
a very real sense,
for some of the things that
we consider characteristic
of basic personhood
in our society.
And the more we can
acknowledge that fight,
and the more we can orient our
discussions around disability
to the concrete and specific
areas of conflict that
drive disability
policy forward and have
over the course of many,
many decades at this point,
the more we can have
a real conversation
to ensure that the
rights of citizenship,
but also the rights
of personhood,
are afforded to all.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
Thank you very much, Ari.
Really thought provoking, and
I appreciate those comments.
And we'll now end--
I think we'll move right
into Charlotte's comments
so that we can then get started
and launch into the discussion.
So Charlotte, the floor is open.
- Thank you very much, Cheri.
And thank you very much for the
invitation to be here today.
I wanted to start off by
just saying that, today,
across the globe,
we're seeing a surge
around the universal recognition
of disability rights.
And it's very important
for us to recognize
that this demand is
predicated on and fueled
by decades of
struggle and results
of the work of the global
disability movement
that Judy talked about.
This movement has
been a movement
that has fought relentlessly
for rights, for recognition,
for dignity, and
very importantly,
for self-representation.
The outcome of this
struggle has been
the construction of a global
architecture around disability.
In that regard, we now
have the Convention
on the Rights of Persons
with Disabilities,
which has been ratified
by 178 countries.
Linked to that or
related to that,
we also have the Sustainable
Development Goals and the 2030
Agenda, which now frames
development programming
across the world.
And so again, very important in
terms of thinking about where
disability is globally.
It's important for us to note
that both of these frameworks
have been replicated at
regional level across the world.
And in their
replication, what we see
is that they're nuanced based
on regional characteristics.
And they're seen as part of
indigenization of the rights
in that particular
part of the world.
As we speak, the
African Union is
about to commence the
process of approving
an African Protocol for
the Rights of Persons
With Disabilities.
The World Disability
Report, a World Bank
and WHO collaboration, estimates
that persons with disabilities
make up at least 15% of
the world's population,
making us the world's
largest minority.
Our collective lived
experience and mobilization
at local level and country
level has been directly,
and I repeat, directly
responsible for the rapid entry
into force of the Convention
on the Rights of Persons
with Disabilities.
And then in turn, this
convention and the engagement
of persons with
disabilities influence
the intergovernmental
negotiations
around the Sustainable
Development Goals,
with the resultant
effect of making
them responsive to
disability and firmly
recognizing disability as part
of the development agenda.
Now, this would not
have happened had it not
been for the global
disability movement.
Increasingly, persons with
disabilities across the globe
have been shaping social
and economic innovations,
challenging social
norms and values,
and breaking new ground.
Similarly, it is
pretty clear to me
that the desire for
recognition of one's own value
and that of a community has
driven the political engagement
of persons with disabilities,
again, across the globe.
Today, across the world,
we have countless numbers
of parliamentarians with
disabilities in Africa,
in Asia, in Latin America.
In Ecuador, we have
President Lenin Moreno,
a president with a disability.
In Argentina, we have a vice
president, Marta Gabriela
Michetti--
a woman with a
visible disability.
And of course, we have our own
Tammy Duckworth in the Senate.
But we need more.
And it's possible.
We need more, and it's possible.
And I'll tell you why
I think it's possible.
It's possible because we
have, ever more than before,
a robust and engaged base
of persons with disabilities
working at the community level
to galvanize and socialize
our rights.
It's also important
for us to recognize
that, for the first time, these
organizations, these groups,
these people are connected
via social media--
connected as never before.
Persons with disabilities
are increasingly
influencing the course
of their communities
and their countries.
For example, based
out of Nairobi, Kenya,
a group of young, African
youth with disabilities
have established a
network using social media
to share their experience and
stand up for disability rights.
They now have a platform
for their shared beliefs,
as citizens with
rights and dignity.
This is very exciting.
At the same time, we cannot
ignore the fact that this
population continues to
face many, many obstacles.
And these range from
stigma, discrimination,
marginalization,
the lack of access
to services, to opportunities,
and very importantly,
to voice in decision making.
If we accept that the
hallmark of citizenship
is the intrinsic worth, and
the value of all people,
and a concept that
continues to evolve,
then we also need to be
mindful of the barriers
that we experience.
We also need to be
mindful of the fact
that our own sense of
worth, as Judy pointed out,
is not sufficient,
particularly where
we live in situations
and communities
where the societal norms
and practices do not
recognize your worth.
So you might think you have
all the worth in the world.
But if other people
and the community
doesn't see your value,
doesn't see your worth,
doesn't recognize
your agency, then
you're in a very
difficult situation.
I wanted to just quickly talk
about the importance of higher
education because,
globally, students
with disabilities
in higher education
remain underrepresented.
We're seeing some increases
in the OECD countries.
But this is, by far, not enough.
We know that on the
employment front,
we also see a lag in terms
of the employment of persons
with disabilities.
The International
Labor Organization
estimates that 386 million
people of working age
have some kind of a disability,
and that in some places,
in some countries in the
world, the unemployment
rate for persons with
disabilities is as high as 80%.
This exclusion of persons with
disabilities from education,
from employment
opportunities, as we know,
is often compounded by the
social disadvantage already
experienced by persons
with disabilities.
And so what does this
mean in real terms?
What it means, for me, is
that too many young people
with disabilities
are not in education,
are not in employment.
And as a category,
as a group of people,
they will be most affected
by economic exclusion
and, linked to that,
multidimensional poverty.
We, therefore,
need to ensure that
their socioeconomic integration
is put in place by tailored
policies and programs.
We need to see more robust
efforts in higher education
and really begin
to systematically,
and in a system-wide way,
address the lag that we see.
We also need to
make institutions
of higher learning more
reflective of our demographics
and of our diversity
as a society.
But I also just want
to pick up on a point,
and that is why we
have seen, globally,
an advancement in
terms of disability,
within the global
disability movement.
We're also having to
contend increasingly
with the politics of
fear and populism.
And this is happening in far
too many parts of the world.
In my view, this movement,
this fear-based politics,
seeks to redefine people
as narrowly identified--
identifying the in
group, and in so doing,
really excludes large
parts of the population
as a whole and
negates those of us
who have intersecting
identities.
I think this is particularly
disquieting for persons
with disabilities because,
as people with disabilities,
we all have
intersecting identities.
These identities
could be gender.
They could be race.
They could be
sexual orientation.
They could be refugee status.
They could be age, and so on.
And so we cannot afford
to valorize othering.
Instead, we have to build
a common narrative that
is underpinned by respect,
non-discrimination, solidarity,
participation, and voice.
And if we do this, it'll
enable us, as a group,
to flourish, to
belong, to recognize
the struggles of those
before us, and to thrive.
If we fail to do
this, there is a risk
that the gains that we have made
to date will be clawed back.
They'll be diluted.
They will be erased.
There is also a risk that
we will be made invisible.
And there's also the
risk of us unwittingly
assuming new forms of
oppression and suppression.
This is particularly
relevant as we
move into the future of work,
to which scientists have already
started to warn us that rapid
strides in the development
of artificial
intelligence and robotics
could threaten the prospects
of mass employment.
And my question is,
what does that mean
for persons with disabilities?
And so I contend that
we have no choice
but to continue bold
and ambitious activism,
activism that ensures that
the aspirations of persons
with disabilities are
demanded and realized
through active citizenship.
And we constantly need
to ask the question, what
does this mean for
persons with disabilities?
We need to rewrite the
narrative of active citizenship
and civil participation
to include
persons with disabilities,
not as the exception, but as
the rule.
In shaping this narrative,
we cannot and should not lose
sight of the need to address
the existing barriers that still
exclude us.
We need to challenge these
barriers like Maria Alejandra
Villanueva did.
Maria is a young woman with
Down Syndrome who lives in Peru.
And she was able to challenge
a discriminatory government
policy and, in so doing,
nullified the policy
that excluded people with
certain mental and intellectual
disabilities from
the electoral rolls.
We need more Marias.
We need to be
seated at the table
to construct dialogue
between the disability
movement, public institutions.
We need to build alliances
with broader civil society.
We need to be part of
political organizations.
And of course, we need
to be visible and active
in the private sector if
we're essential-- if we
are to move the discourse
from inclusion to empowerment.
And I want to repeat that
because I think we really
need to think about moving the
discourse around disability
from inclusion to empowerment.
We know that facilitating
disability inclusion
enables the mobilization
of a new generation.
But we also need to see more
young people with disabilities
as economic and social resources
who can, as citizens, directly
contribute to sustaining the
stability and economic growth
of our country.
However, we cannot
do this alone.
Using the capabilities approach,
the work of Sen and Nussbaum,
we have advanced the
conceptualization
of disability, but
we need more of that.
The work that my dear friends
Michael and Cheri lead
is well-respected globally
and highly sought after.
We need more Cheris.
We need more Michaels.
And so allow me, Chair,
to use my last minute
to invite academia to partner
with us to better define
the discourse around
disability and citizenship,
on issues around how we
measure participation.
How do we enhance participation?
There is a lot to do, and
I hope this conference is
the beginning of this journey.
So let me just close
with an African proverb
that I think sums up my
remarks and, in many ways,
says it in a lot
more eloquent way.
And it says, "If you want
to go fast, go alone.
But if you want to
go far, go together."
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
Thank you very much, Charlotte.
So I'm going to kick off
with a couple of questions
for the panel that I think will
touch upon the points brought
up and maybe bring up a
few new points, as well.
So if I could, Maria, I'm going
to tap you on the shoulder
first since I'm sitting
right next to you.
- OK.
- And I think it's really
interesting to think about this
cross-generational perspective.
In your experience now
with the City of Houston,
but also working with Public
Engagement with the Obama White
House, it seemed like you were
really able to bring together
a community of young voices
of people with disabilities.
And as we think about
this ADA Generation,
obviously, there's a very
empower-- it's very empowered
lens.
But also, conversely, do you
think there's any risk there?
Do you think that a
younger generation
is at risk of forgetting
the past in any way and all
the work that's been done?
Or how are you seeing
people respond to that?
- I don't think so.
I actually think that the
vast majority of youth
with disabilities don't
have access to the past,
so they don't have
a way to forget it.
There is still an enormous lack
of recognition and awareness
of disability history.
And that's everything from
a history of the disability
rights movement,
to knowing that one
of the signers of the
Declaration of Independence
was a person with a disability,
to recognizing that Harriet
Tubman was a disabled woman.
And I also think that many
young people with disabilities
do not know and
don't have a chance
to learn what their rights are.
And I'm going to
probably, a little bit,
mess up a saying from the
self-advocacy movement, which
is essentially that we invest
so much time, and energy,
and money in getting our
children to talk only
to tell them to shut up.
And I think that for many youth
with disabilities growing up
today, at least for myself--
because we have access to things
like mainstream education,
we are-- the primary
message that we receive
about our disability is to
pass, be as normal and as
non-disabled as possible.
And that is extremely toxic,
and it's extremely dangerous.
And so I think that once
youth with disabilities
are able to learn about the
past and learn about the fights,
it is actually motivation
to get more engaged.
I also think youth with
disabilities growing up now,
like every young
person in the country,
is seeing how easily our
rights can be threatened,
and the importance of that
vigilance that President Obama
talked about.
I also think, too, many young
people with disabilities
are having to learn how to
attack much more subtle,
but none the less, dangerous
forms of discrimination.
So for example, young
people with disabilities
are growing up with
the expectation
that they will have a job.
They prepare their resume.
They put on their suits.
They get an interview.
They get to the interview
and are ultimately
denied the job
because they're told,
you're just not the right fit.
You can't take, you're
just not the right fit,
and sue that employer for
disability discrimination.
Even though embedded in,
you're just not the right fit,
is, you look different.
That scares me, and I don't
know if I can work with you.
And so I think that
the tactics that youth
will have to use to
really dig into things
like that, those subtle--
subtle comments connected
to much more dangerous forms
of discrimination are going to
be different than generations
previous because they were
attacking very explicit,
tangible forms of bias.
So--
- Yeah.
It does look a
little different now.
But I think I've experienced
many of the same things
from the standpoint of--
I think that I know,
personally, as I approached
a career in medicine,
for example,
that probably a
lot of my success--
particularly early on, when I
didn't have a lot of mentors,
myself, to look
at-- was the tactics
of passing, of keeping
up, and doing the job,
and making it work in
whatever way would get it done
at the end of the day,
but not necessarily doing
that with a positive
identity of disability
or bringing that to
the table, as well.
Charlotte, on a
similar vein, you
talked a little bit about
mobilization of younger
generations in Africa.
Can you talk a little
bit more about--
as we are living in a world with
so much more interconnectedness
with regards to things
like social media
and other forms of
reaching across borders,
do you see advocacy
happen differently
in places where people
may not have previously
been able to talk to
each other as easily,
and particularly those younger
generations who are coming
into it with that lens?
- So I mean, I definitely see
a lot more use of social media.
But I think we also need to just
acknowledge our own privilege
because in a lot of
places where I work, just
getting onto the internet
is very difficult.
It costs a lot when you can.
And so we need to
be mindful of that.
But I do think that there
are groups-- as I mentioned,
the group that works out of
Nairobi that works TransAfrica,
and they're really good.
They're really good about
sharing positive stories,
about sharing new laws
that are coming up.
And they are very, very engaged.
Now, I think what--
the way that group
was established
was that it got some funding
from the Open Society
Foundation, which is great.
But those type of things should
be happening organically.
My greatest fear
is, what happens
when the funding runs dry?
So it's really important
for us to recognize
these types of
initiatives, but find
ways to make them indigenous
to Nairobi, to Lagos,
or wherever it is.
And so, yeah.
I mean, I think it's happening,
but it could happen a lot more.
- Yeah, exactly.
And Ari, I wanted to ask
you a little bit about-- you
know, in your work across
policy, and so many
of the things that
you said resonated,
I know, personally
with me, with regards
to having the
choice to take risks
and to be able to make that
decision independently.
Have you seen-- as we enter into
this current political climate
and with a lot of the
challenges that we're in,
do you see people from
within the disability
community becoming more engaged,
or as the challenges mount,
more disenfranchised, or both?
I mean, I think some
people get fired up
and want to be
even more involved.
And other people just
think it's just too much.
And the barriers are
so high that they
tend to pull back a little bit.
Have you seen any major
trends in that way?
- So of course, the answer
that I'd like to give,
and the answer
that we're supposed
to give in moments like this,
is that the disability rights
movement is united as one
in this overwhelming wave
of passion and is
voting as a bloc.
And the tragic thing is
that it's not really true.
In so far as we have data,
we know that, in general,
people with disabilities follow,
in terms of political opinions,
some of the same patterns
as the broader public.
And you know, as Judy
alluded to earlier, usually,
folks don't take an
identity-first conception
of their disability.
And so while we, in some
sense, have tens of millions
of people, a large voting
bloc, practically, we
haven't seen voting patterns
really track with that.
Now, there are some
very significant ways
in which the disability
community does mobilize around
candidates and policy issues
that speak very directly
to their interests.
I think we saw that
in the context of--
two years ago, in the fight
over Medicaid per capita caps
and the attempt to repeal
the Affordable Care Act.
We saw significant mobilization
of the disability community
and, particularly, of
disability rights groups.
But we're continuously
facing this challenge
that there's the
disability rights
community, and the
disability rights culture,
and infrastructure, and so on.
And then there's this
vastly larger group
of people who just happened
to have disabilities.
And if we want to increase the
effectiveness of the disability
rights community,
we have to expand
it to encompass more than
just a small percentage
of the disability
community, because that's
the way that we're going
to start meaningfully
influencing voting
patterns and really
come into political maturity
as a stakeholder group.
- Yeah.
That's a really
important perspective.
Thank you.
So we'll now open it
up to the audience
for some Q&A. So
please, does anybody
have a first question
for the panelists?
Looks like right here.
- Hi there.
My name's Mandy Curtis.
I'm a social worker
who actually worked
in the medical field
for a few years,
and now I run a private
practice that works
a little bit on disability.
I've been legally
blind since birth,
and I do adaptive rock climbing.
I was thinking a
lot about what we've
discussed in terms of in group
and out group, citizenship,
and global participation.
And I've noticed we've talked
a lot about young people
and youth, and I
think there's been
kind of a focus of
discussion on people
who have had disability and
kind of grown up with it
from a young age.
Something that I've interacted
with a lot in my life
and in my work is,
in fact, adults
who have acquired
disability, or have maybe
grown up with a condition but
not known what it was, or had
their disability changed the way
their body functions over time.
And I think I have come to some
thoughts about this on my own.
But I would love to open
this up to a panel of people
who are very experienced
in these different ways,
and ask you, what do you
think are ways that we--
as a community, but within our
societies and our cultures--
kind of open the
door for people who
have experienced
the shock and even
the loss of acquiring
a disability,
and having to
relate to their body
and to their
community in a new way
that they really maybe not--
they didn't really have
control over at the time?
How do we kind of make space
for that complicated journey
and integration of possibly
acquiring a new identity?
- Cheri, can I maybe
take a shot at that?
- Absolutely.
- So I was injured in a
car crash as an adult.
I'd just graduated
from law school.
And so I--
I mean, I know exactly
what you're talking about.
Acquiring a disability at
that age, for me, was--
I had a life, like
before and after.
It was really that clear.
And it was also very clear to me
about how people perceived me.
And so there was a lot of--
aside from the fact that I
was learning my own body,
people around me
were having to learn
how to interact with me
because there was-- there
continued to be this
fear, if you want,
this subliminal fear about
my newly-acquired disability.
I had a lot of people who
were praying for me every day.
That didn't work.
[LAUGHTER]
I had a lot of people who
just couldn't deal with it.
They just could
not deal with it.
But then I had some
amazing people.
I mean, my family
was incredible.
I had a lot of people
who just really made sure
that I was given all
of the opportunities
to make sure that I could
continue to do the work that I
wanted to do.
On a personal level,
I was also very clear
that I didn't want to be
the disability lawyer.
And so for the first
couple of years,
I was totally not engaged
in the disability agenda.
I was working on
children's rights.
I was working on social
and economic rights.
I did not want to be pigeonholed
as the disability lawyer.
But as we know, that
doesn't last for too long.
Increasingly, my work
on children's rights
were about children
with disabilities.
Increasingly, my work
around prisoners' rights
was to find out what was
happening with prisoners
with disabilities.
And then I just
thought, you know,
I just need to be true
to myself and call it.
And I think, obviously, it was
the best thing I've ever done.
But I do think that
there's a transition,
and people experience
that very differently.
But, yeah.
So that was my story.
- Can I also answer
that question?
- Absolutely.
- What was your name?
- Mandy.
Mandy, that was a
fantastic question,
and I'm so glad you raised it.
The vast majority of people
with disabilities in the United
States are older adults.
And they're older adults
who have most likely
aged into disability.
And so to kind of
add color to what Ari
was saying about
voting blocs and how
we don't vote as a
big disability vote,
it's because the
majority of those voters
are older adults who will say
things like, I just don't hear
as well as I used to.
And the vast majority
of people that I
work with in my office in
Houston are older adults.
And so when I am usually on
the phone with, let's say,
a 70-year-old woman with limited
English who is becoming blind
due to diabetes, and she is
talking to me about how scared
she is, and about how much--
how hard this is for her, the
first thing that I have to do
is respect that.
What I cannot do is say, oh,
but it's OK to be disabled,
and you should have
disability pride.
I can't do that.
That's going to shut
down the conversation.
And what I find myself
doing, many times,
is very, very slowly trying to
not only connect individuals
to resources, but to community,
because what I have found
is that community
can save lives.
And I have a story here.
So during Hurricane
Harvey, I think
one of the greatest
public health crises
that Houston faced was
older adults who, again,
aged into disability, were not
connected to disability support
systems, and were living
very tentative existences.
And we worked with a man
whose name was Mr. Johnson.
Mr. Johnson was blind
because of a car accident.
He had diabetes, and he
had lymphedema in his legs.
His leg wraps became
contaminated with floodwater,
and so his legs became infected.
And so he was at significant
risk of losing his legs.
And it was always
tricky to call Mr.
Johnson because he couldn't--
he had not been taught to use
assistive technology
and was blind.
So you would have to
call him and leave
a voicemail, which
he would then try
to write down to call you back.
And he couldn't tell
us what kind of leg
wraps he needed because
he couldn't see the labels
and wasn't connected to people
who could come in and read them
for him.
And so what we did was basically
sent out a disability welcoming
wagon to Mr. Johnson's
house so that he could see,
one, people with
limited mobility
who were able to help him--
these were the folks
that brought him food--
and connect him to
other blind folks.
And I remember, he called
me three months later.
And he said, Ms. Maria,
thank you for introducing me
to Maria and Michael.
They saved my life.
And so I think we
need to develop
better systems of
exposing people
who are aging into disability
to community because, to them,
it's just a sign of their
fragility and their mortality,
which, if we're all being
honest with ourselves,
are very hard to contend with.
- I was struck, and
I've been struck
over the course of the
last several years,
by how the disability community
and the idea of disability
culture really needs to be
referred to more in the plural
than in the singular.
It's very challenging because
we want to be able to say, well,
people with
disabilities want this.
You know, folks say,
people with disabilities
want you to refer to them
with person-first language.
But in reality, for
some communities,
that's not the case.
The autistic community,
the deaf community,
the blind community--
there's often a preference
for identity-first language.
We want to be able to say,
people with disabilities
don't want to cure.
Well, for many
disability groups,
folks do, very
intensely, want to cure.
And for others, we
very intensely don't.
And I think the challenge
that we run into
is we built this really powerful
political coalition that
came together to pass
the ADA, and defend it,
and to fight for
disability rights
in a variety of contexts.
But that political
coalition is really
a hodge-podge of dramatically
different kinds of experiences
and people who
think of themselves
in dramatically different ways.
And so the more that we can
start thinking of the first
point of contact
for, especially,
folks with newly
acquired disabilities--
but even folks who've grown up
with their disabilities but are
looking for a disability
community for the first time--
to be their native part of
the disability community,
rather than trying to take
our political coalition
and turn it into something that
it really hasn't been, except
for a small number
of people culturally.
I think the better
off we're going to be.
And the good news is that there
are a lot of folks doing that.
And there are a lot of
folks doing excellent work
to continue to build,
and grow, and expand
the different
disability cultures that
carry such resonance for
so many different people.
- Thank you, Ari.
So with that-- actually, that
was such a rich question,
thank you--
and such a rich discussion
that we used up the time.
Now, I will say that I
think all of our panelists
would be very open to answering
further questions one-on-one
after this formal session ends.
But I also don't want to cut
into people's break time, which
is, of course, very important.
So with this, we'll break.
How long, Becky?
For 25 minutes.
Please remember that there
are accessible bathrooms.
There's plenty of
folks in the back.
Just please ask, if you
have any questions regarding
where to find that.
And let's please
have another round
of applause for our amazing
panelists, Maria, Ari,
and Charlotte.
[APPLAUSE]
And we'll see you
back very soon.
Thank you.